i want to finish up with the sorrow
story kai can you pull up the soros
video i don't know if you guys saw what
happened with soros
it's a little disturbing okay it's a
little disturbing for me
and if if you have the video go click on
uh
do you have it or you don't have a kai i
think you do have it somewhere there is
there
no not that one although that's a cool
video i saw that it was good you added
that video by the way to it i saw it
last night
uh uh uh just kai if you can't find it
just go type in
yeah so i don't know if you guys saw
what happened the other day luis did you
see this
have you guys seen what happened with
soros and newt gingrich the other day on
fox
no you didn't see it i did do you know
who george soros is
no idea okay so george you're going to
find out
he's a legendary hockey player who
played for the kings
as the goalie uh uh a great defender
let me see move off of it because it's
the video that's like minute okay go to
minute 46 the 275 000. yeah
click on that one you open it up like
that interesting
all right fast forward a little bit guy
[Music]
uh keep going droid by this point going
keep going keep going
for us i don't think youtube's like look
the number one problem in almost all
these cities
is george soros elected left-wing
anti-police pro-criminal district
attorneys
who refuse to keep people locked up
uh just yesterday they put somebody back
on the street
who's wanted for two different murders
in new york city
uh you cannot solve this problem
and both harris and biden have talked
very proudly
progressive pro-criminal and
overwhelmingly elected with george soros
as much watch this and that's a major
cause
of the violence we're seeing because
they keep putting the violent criminals
back on the street
i'm not sure we need to bring george
soros into this i'm not sure we need to
bring george for watching wow i was
going to say you'd get the last word
speaker he paid for it
i mean why can't we discuss the fact
that millions of dollars i agree with
jordan doesn't need to be a part of this
conversation
who is she okay
so it's verbose all right
okay who is she first of all that that
very uncomfortable when i saw that well
and the woman in the previous
video who said that george soros doesn't
need to be a part of the conversation
was actually former obama administrative
administration state department staffer
marie harf
she was yeah the blonde girl
the blonder was adam do you have
anything to say on this are you just
kind of flabbergasted
i mean it's good now um
this is actually perfect timing the the
fact that i did this interview with
daryl davis yesterday again if you guys
have not in our audience have not
seen anything with daryl davis please
google him check out what he has done
he's been on
rogan he's been on cnn he's got
documentaries galore
and he basically meets with kkk klansmen
and convinces them
or sparks something in their mind to get
them to leave the clan
okay so one of the i'll give you a few
of his perspectives and quotes and he
says
i may not agree with what you say but i
defend
your right to say it cool that's the
first amendment
and for sure we need different
perspectives there's nothing that we
have this is the first amendment
i might not agree with what you're
saying but you can say it this is
america
right and his keys and it's what makes
america different than everywhere else
exactly i don't get that so you need to
listen
to other people and respect other
people's opinions yeah but
listen and respect this is bigger than
that though this is bigger than that
this is
this is controlling the narrative with
fox
this is fox uh uh having
having being afraid of somebody saying
something the host
is stopped and says wait you can't say
that that's not true
that's like in the middle of a debate
when when you see
hillary is debating trump and trump says
something
the moderator says you're wrong rather
than asking a question but doesn't say
you're wrong to hillary
let them debate then you say you're
wrong the next day you can't
jump in and do this but the media is now
doing this